microsoft azure is a growing set of
cloud-based computing services offered
to corporations developers government
organizations and anybody else who wants
to build an app or run a business on the
internet
without having to install and manage
hardware or server software
but this much information is not enough
to understand the complete cycle of its
concepts
and that is what i'm here for hey
everyone welcome to this new video on
simply learn on azure tutorial for
beginners
in this video i'll take you around
crucial azure services and their
in-depth concepts
so without doing any further ado let's
start with the
video but before diving into the azure
world let's have a quick introduction to
what is cloud computing
so cloud computing is the distribution
of computing services while the internet
including servers storage databases
networking software analytics
and intelligence
to provide faster innovation more
flexible resources and economies of
skill
you usually only pay for the cloud
services you use which helps you cut
cost
run your infrastructure more efficiently
and scale as your business grows
so this was all about cloud computing
now let's start with the star of this
video that is azure
first let's understand what is microsoft
azure
microsoft azure is a growing set of
cloud-based computing services
offered to corporation
developers government
and anybody else who wants to build an
app or run a business on the internet
without having to install and manage
hardware or server software
in recent years it has eclipsed both
windows and office in terms of sales
making it microsoft fastest growing
business sector
the azure platform is designed to assist
organizations in overcoming obstacles
and achieving their objectives it
supports a wide range of industries
including e-commerce
finance and a number of organization
and it is open source compatible
this gives consumers the freedom to use
whatever tools and technologies they
want
now coming to how azure works
customers who subscribe to azure get
access to all of the services
available through the azure interface
these services allow subscribers to
create cloud-based resources
such as virtual machines
and databases
azure comes with five different customer
support solutions from microsoft basic
developer standard professional direct
and premier
the scope and cost of these customer
assistance programs vary all azure
accounts get basic assistance for free
however microsoft charges a premium for
the other support options
developer support is 29 per month
100 per month for standard assistance
and 1 000 per month for professional
direct support
microsoft does not provide pricing
information for premier support
now that we have covered the basics of
microsoft azure
let's dive down and explore the services
offered by azure
well
there are multiple services offered by
azure like machine learning analytics
containers
compute databases developer tools
devops hybrid and multi-cloud
identity
integration
internet of things
management media
migration mobile networking security
storage web and virtual desktop
but among these we will be discussing
only a few which are widely used by
organizations and
individuals around the world and we will
be vividly discussing these features in
depth
and these services are compute
containers databases identity security
networking and storage
now let's start with the first one that
is
compute
azure compute is a service that allows
you to run cloud-based applications
on demand
disk cpus memory
networking and operating systems are
among the computing resources it
supplies
and the resources are on demand and can
be accessed in minutes
or even seconds you only pay for what
you use and for how long you use it
azure offers a variety of computing
solutions for development and testing
application deployment and data center
expansion
linux windows server sql server oracle
ibm and sap are all supported by the
servers
the following are some of the most
well-known services azure virtual
machines virtual machine scale sets
azure container instances azure app
service
and azure functions or also serverless
computing
now let's discuss each of this one by
one
first is azure virtual machines
virtual machines are software based
computer simulations
a virtual processor memory storage and
networking resources are among the
resources available
virtual machines or vms run on operating
system and allow you to install and run
software much like a regular computer
you can use and operate the virtual
machine as if you were sitting in front
of it by utilizing a remote desktop
client
azure virtual machines allow you to
construct and operate virtual machines
in the cloud
infrastructure as a service is provided
through virtual machines
and they can be used in a variety of
ways
virtual machines are an excellent
solution when you need complete control
over an operating system
and its surroundings
all of the software running on the vm
can be customized
just as on a real machine
also
when you are running custom software or
hosting arrangements this capability
comes in handy
now coming on to the next one that is
virtual machine scale sets
scale sets are an azure compute resource
that may be used to deploy and manage a
group of identical virtual machines
virtual machine scale sets are meant to
provide real auto scale when all vms are
set up the same
virtual machines do not need to be
pre-provisioned as a result
developing large-scale services for big
computing big data and containerized
workloads is easy
more vm instances can be added as demand
grows
vm instances can be withdrawn when
demand decreases
the procedure might be human
automated or a hybrid of the two
now moving on to the next one that is
azure container instances
container instances are azure compute
resources for managing and deploying
containers
containers are virtualized
application
environments that are lightweight
they're built to be dynamically formed
scaled
and stopped
on a single host machine you can run
many instances of a containerized
application
then comes azure app services
you can create deploy and scale
enterprise grade web mobile and api apps
on any platform with azure app service
while employing a fully managed platform
to handle infrastructure maintenance you
can meet stringent performance
scalability
security and compliance requirements a
platform as a service solution is app
service
and following that we have azure
functions
when you simply care about the code that
runs your service and not the underlying
platform or infrastructure functions are
great
they're frequently used when you need to
respond to an event typically via our
esd request
a timer or a message from another azure
service and the job can be accomplished
rapidly in seconds or less
now that we have completed all the
services offered by compute
let's proceed to the next one
that is
containers
containers are a type of virtualization
system
you can run several containers on a
single physical or virtual host in the
same way that you can run numerous
virtual machines on a single physical
host
unlike virtual machines you don't have
control over a container's operating
system
containers are lightweight and designed
to be built
scaled out and stopped dynamically
whereas virtual machines appear to be
instance of an operating system that you
can connect
to and administer
containers are built to help you to
react to changes on the go
containers allow you to swiftly resume
in the event of a crash of hardware
failure
docker is one of the most popular
container engines and azure supports it
containers offer these particular
servers
container instances
azure container services and container
registry
container instances
are the quickest and easiest method to
operate a container in the azure without
needing to manage virtual machines
or use any extra services
it's a power service that lets you
upload your containers
and have them run for you
moving on to the next one are azure
container services
azure container services or azure
kubernetes services allows users to
manage deploy and control operations of
kubernetes container
orchestration is a term used to describe
the process of automating managing and
interacting with a large number of
containers
as azure kubernetes service is a
comprehensive container orchestration
service for distributed architectures
and high volumes of containers
and then comes container registry
a container registry is used to ease
container development by easing storage
and management of container images
now that we have covered containers and
the services offered let's move on to
the next azure service that is
databases
azure database is a fully managed
platform as a service
database engine that automates the
majority of database management tasks
such as updating patching backups and
monitoring
microsoft has released a managed
instance aimed at on-premises clients so
if we have any sql databases on premises
that we want to migrate to azure without
any complex configuration or ambiguity
we can use manage instances the most
prominent services under database
service are
as your cosmos db as your sql database
and azure post free sql
now coming to the azure cosmos db
as your cosmos db is a multi-modal
globally distributed database service
you may increase throughput and storage
across any number of azure locations
around the world in an elastic and
independent manner
you can use any way of several common
apis to get single digit millisecond
data access
throughput latency availability and
consistency assurances are all covered
by azure cosmos db's service level
agreements
now azure cosmos db enables schema less
data allowing you to create extremely
responsive and always-on apps
that can handle constantly changing data
this functionality can be used to store
data that has been updated and
maintained by users all around the world
so next comes azure sql database
azure sql database is a relational
database based on the microsoft sql
server database engine's most recent
stable version
sql database is a fast dependable
well-managed and secure database
you may use it to create data driven
applications and websites in your
preferred programming language without
having to worry about infrastructure
so sql databases pass capabilities
allows you to concentrate on the domain
specific database administration
and optimization tasks that are vital to
your business
sql database is a fully managed service
with high availability backups
and other typical maintenance features
built in
microsoft is in charge of sql and
operating system code changes
you don't have to worry about the
infrastructure
coming to the next one the azure post
free sql
now azure database the post free sql
is a cloud-based relational database
solution
the server software is based on the open
source poetry sql database
engines community
when you use azure database for a
postgresql your experience with tools
and knowledge
comes in handy
moreover
it has various benefits like in
comparison to on premises resources
there is built in high availability
to ensure that your apps are always
online
no additional configuration replication
or cost is necessary
pricing is straightforward and adaptable
you can expect consistent performance
thanks to a pricing track tire that
includes software patching automatic
backups monitoring and security
within seconds scale up or down as
needed to ensure that your service
adapts to usage you can draw computation
and storage independently
as needed
automatic backups can be customized and
restored to a specific point in time for
up to 35 days
and enterprise level security
to safeguard sensitive data in transit
and at rest this prediction
includes
data encryption on disk as well as ssl
encryption for client server
communication
now we have covered one more crucial
service offered by azure now let's move
ahead and explore another service that
is security and identity
these two services are integrated
so we will be discussing them together
identity management in specific is a
process of authenticating first and then
authorizing using security principles
and it involves controlling information
about those principle identities
it provides these important services
as your security center
key volt and very important aspect of
azure service that is azure active
directory
azure security center
first azure security center is a
collection of tools for monitoring and
managing the security of virtual
machines and other cloud computing
resources
in microsoft's public cloud
the azure security center is accessed
through the azure management interface
by administrators
they may find a number of security tools
in the security center to help them
prevent identify
and respond to possible security risk
to the azure deployment
to use the security center organizations
must have an azure subscription
next is
azure keyword
azure key vault is a cloud service for
storing and accessing secrets in a
secure manner anything you want to
restrict access to such as api keys
passwords certificates or cryptographic
keys is a secret
vol's a managed and hardness security
module
pools are two types of containers
supported by the keyword service
software as well as hsm backed keys
secrets and certificates can be stored
in words only hsm back keys are
supported by manage as hsm pools
coming to the next one is azure active
directory
azure active directory or azure edi is a
cloud-based identity and access
management service from microsoft
that allows your employees to sign in
and access resources such as microsoft
365 the azure portal and thousands of
other sas apps
internal resources such as apps on your
company's intranet and network as well
as any cloud apps built by a company
azure ad is required for sign-in and
identity protection in microsoft online
business
such as microsoft 365 and azure
if you sign up for any microsoft online
businesses
you will be given access to azure ad
which includes
all of the free services
now we covered one more azure service
let's move on to the next service which
is networking
now
azure provides the scalability
performance high availability and
enterprise-grade security
you need to satisfy your most extreme
workloads requirements with more than 1
lakh 65 000 miles of
fibers across 60 plus regions and 170
plus network pops around the world
customers will have a consistent low
latency experience thanks to service
and integrate smoothly across
on-premises multi-cloud and edge
locations
so when you use azure networking's
network as a service you can concentrate
on delivering your application logic
network watcher express root monitor
azure monitor or vnet
terminal access point are all azure
networking services that can be used to
monitor your network resources
so the first one we will talk about are
virtual network
azure virtual networks allow azure
services such as virtual machines web
apps and databases to connect with one
another with internet users and with
on-premises client computers
an azure network is a collection of
resources that connects other azure
resources isolation and segmentation
internet communications
communicate among
azure resources communicating with
on-premises resources
route network traffic filter network
traffic and connect virtual networks are
some of the core networking features
provided by azure virtual networks
next we will talk about vpn gateway
a virtual network gateway or vpn gateway
is a form of the virtual network gateway
azure
instances are installed in azure virtual
network instances and provide
connectivity for services such as
a site-to-site connection connects
on-premises data centers to virtual
networks
a point-to-site link connects individual
devices to virtual networks and a
network to network connection
connects virtual networks to other
virtual networks
so now moving on in express route
with the support of a connectivity
provider express route allows you to
expand your on-premises networks into
the microsoft cloud over a private
connection
you can connect to microsoft cloud
services such as microsoft azure and
microsoft 365 using express root
and any to any ipvpn network a
point-to-point ethernet network
or a virtual cross-connection through a
connectivity provider at a co-location
facility
can all be used for connectivity
so express root connections are not made
through a public network
as a result
express root connections provide more
reliability
quicker speed constant latencies
and higher security than traditional
internet connections
now we have reached the last service
offered by azure
that we will discuss
storage
microsoft azure storage platform is a
cloud storage technology designed for
current data storage scenarios
a massive scalable object stored for
data object disk storage for azure
virtual machines a file system service
for the cloud
a messaging store for reliable
communications and a nosql store that
are all available through core storage
services
the services offered by r
as your blob storage as your table
storage
as your queue storage and azure file
storage
so the first one is azure blob storage
blob storage is a microsoft azure
service for storing binary big objects
made up of unstructured material like
text photos and videos as well as
associated metadata
blob storage objects can be accessed
through http or https from anywhere in
the globe by users or clients
applications
blob storage objects can be accessed
using the azure storage rest api azure
power cell and azure cli or a client
library for azure storage
coming to the next one is azure table
storage
large volumes of structured data are
stored
in azure table storage the service is a
no sql data store that takes requests
from both inside and outside the azure
cloud
now azure tables are great for storing
non-relational structured data
table storage can be used to store and
query large amount of structured
non-relational data and it will scale as
demand growth
moving on to the next one that is azure
queue storage
azure queue storage is a service that
allows you to store massive amounts of
data
authenticated http or https call allow
you access the messages from anywhere in
the world
a queue message can have a maximum size
of 64 kb
a queue can hold millions of messages
up to the storage of accounts overall
capacity limit
queues are widely used to build a
backlog of work for asynchronous
processing
now coming to the last one is azure file
storage
azure files provides fully managed cloud
files
that can be accessed via the industry
standard server message block or network
file system protocols
cloud and on-premises and deployments
can both mount azure files
file shares at the same time
windows linux and mac os clients can
access smb azure file shares
clients running linux or mac os can
access nfs azure file shares
additionally using ad your file
synchronization
smb azure file shares can be cached
on windows servers for rapid access near
where the data is used
so now that we have covered all of the
important services offered by azure and
their first functionality
let's dive deeper into into the concept
and look into how azure is better than
other cloud platforms
so
first is microsoft azure pass
gives developers the environment tools
and building blocks they need to create
and deploy
new cloud services quickly it also
provides the critical devops linkages
required for monitoring maintaining and
fine-tuning such apps
microsoft handles much of the
infrastructure management behind the
scenes with azure pass
as a result azure deployment
allows for a singular emphasis on
innovations
second is the compatibility of azure
with one of the most beneficial feature
of azure
and that is the.net programming language
which gives microsoft a significant
advantage
over aws and the rest of the competition
azure was designed and tuned to work
seamlessly with both
old and new apps built on the platform
framework for dotnet programming
now azure was built using the security
development cycle which is a leading
insurance process
in the industry it has security at its
core
ensuring that private data and services
are kept secure and protected while on
azure cloud
fourth is
on azure hybrid apps like can be created
that take advantage of resources in data
centers at the service provider's end
or within azure itself
to increase usability and speed azure
now offers a greater selection of hybrid
connections
such as virtual private networks caches
content delivery networks and express
root connections
fifth is
if a company already utilizes microsoft
software it is likely to be covered by
microsoft enterprise agreement
it is eligible to discounts on microsoft
software because microsoft frequently
modifies these agreements to reduce
azure pricing
as a result of the enterprise agreement
businesses can often get large discounts
for adopting azure
let's have a quick demo for azure
services for their better understanding
so in this demo we will first create a
resource group
and an sql database for it
and a server also
so first you need to login in your
microsoft azure account
and
then click here and go to resource
groups
click on create
button so for subscription we will have
our free trial option
and give it a name according to our
requirement
like for now i'm giving it
as your
demo
simply
and the region according to your uh
area like where you want to deploy your
apps where you
that you will be publishing here
and click on review
plus create
here you will get all the information
that you need to review that all the
information here are correct or not and
then click on create button
it will take a few seconds
now you can see this notification that
your resource
group is created and here you can see
that
your the name of your resource group the
subscription and the location
so now what we need to do is we will
create a
sql database for it
here you can see all the details
so to create our sql database uh we will
first need to
create a web app
so
where we need to go is
we will go to app services
and here we will click on create button
and again we need to give it a first we
need to select our resource group so we
will click on the resource group we just
created
and we will
give it a name
so here
i'm giving it as your
demo
simply web app
and click on code
so that
while publishing we can upload our code
and
runtime stack we can
select
the language we have created our
application in
again the region
and click on review
plus create
so here you can just review all the
details you just
mentioned
it's taking a while
yeah so here you can see subscription
resource group which you just created
name you gave and
the publishing
runtime stack
now all you need to do is click on
create
you can see it's initializing deployment
you need to be very careful with the
region because sometimes it may create
problem while deploying
you can see deployment is in progress
now you can see your deployment is
completed
so
you just need to go to resources
coming back to the page you can see uh
the name of
your application you just created
now as we are done with our web app
now we need to create our
sql database
so coming to the sql database page we
will click on create button
again the subscription we have to give
free trial
and the resource group we just created
because that's what where we are
publishing our web application
and that's where we need to create uh
attach our database with
so now we need to give a name to our
database
so here i'm giving
so i'm giving it a demo sqldb
and
here you can see that we don't have any
items to select as a server so we will
click on create new
here we will create a server for our sql
database
and
give it a name
so i'm giving it a
name
this is
sorry
i'm giving it a name as your simply
server
as you can see it's already taken so i
need to change it
so
let's take azure
demo server
yeah
so now we are done with the name again
for location we need to mention the
region
so here you can see i've selected
now coming
here we have to enter our admin login so
here i'm giving my organization's name
i need to give it a password
then confirm password
and click on ok
so
here you can see
that database name has already been
attached to it
the database we just created
for elastic pool we will go for no
option only
and then again we will click on review
plus create
so here you can see all of the
information
that you just mentioned
whatever privileges you will have with
your sql database
and click on create
you can see
deployment has been initialized
it's gonna take a while
you can see the status
constantly and track them
here you can see deployment is in
progress and in know why you will see
the name being flashed over here
now you can see your deployment is
completed and in deployment details you
can see your database been created
and the demo server you just created
now
going back to your resource group
the one we created at first
clicking on the name
we can see all the tasks we just did
like creating a web app
creating a database for it and also a
server for your database
now all you need to do is publish your
application that you created for
yourself
and deploy it over
here
so this is all in our demo i hope you
liked it and learned something from it
and see you in the next tutorial
well this was all about microsoft azure
and its revolving concepts
i hope you find this video informative
we have almost reached the end of this
video
if i missed anything important do let me
know in the comment section i hope you
enjoyed this video and learn something
new from it
if you like this video then please do
hit the like button thanks for watching
this video and stay tuned for more
updates and videos from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you